[موسيقى]
لم يجب الدخان عن سماء سيفاستوبول حتى عاد
من جديد للمره الثانيه خلال 24 ساعه تتعرض
المدينه جنوبي القرم لهجوم اوكراني يقول
حاكم المدينه الروسيه ان الدفاعات الجويه
تصدت لهجوم صاروخي سقط حطامه في مرفا
المدينه كالامس تعلق حركه نقل الركاب في
خليج سيفاستبول ففي الامس تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها استهدفت اجتماعا لقياده
البحريه الروسيه ما ادى الى مقتل تسعه من
القاده العسكريين الروس في المدينه كانت
موسكو قد اكدت حينها ان جنديا واحدا فقط
قتل في الهجوم اذ استهدفت كييف مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وذلك اسطول يتبع
للبحريه الروسيه ووظيفته تامين الحدود
الجنوبيه لروسيا كما يملك قطعا عسكريه
بحريه متنوعه تعزز الوجود العسكريه
الروسيه في بحري ازوف والاسود وهما بحراني
تنطلق منهما العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
المناطق الجنوبيه من اوكرانيا سواء
بالصواريخ التي تطلق من القطع البحريه
هناك او بالامداد اللوجستيه للقوات البريه
في شبه جزيره القرم منطلق الهجمات الروسيه
في الجبهه الجنوبيه هكذا تتحول القرن
وسبستبول تحديدا الى مركز استراتيجي
لروسيا سياسيا وعسكريا وهدف استراتيجيا
لاوكرانيا عسكريا باضعاف خط الامداد
الرئيسي في المنطقه الجنوبيه للروس
وسياسيا بالتاكيد على احقيه كييف بضرب
اراضيها المحتله كما تقول منذ عام 2014
غير بعيد عن القرم والسباستوبول
الاستراتيجيه يتواصل القتال على خطوط
التماس الجنوبيه هناك تسعى القوات
الاوكرانيه بكل قوتها الى تحقيق اختراق
حقيقي نحو القرم من الجهه الشماليه تستهدف
مدينه
الواقعه على خط القطار الرئيسي من زبولوجي
نحو القرن تقول تلك القوات انها الحقت
خسائر فادحه في الجيش الروسي هناك غير
بعيد عن زبروجيا تقول القوات الروسيه انها
قتلت اربعه الاف جندي اوكراني على خطوط
الجبهه هناك خلال الاسبوع الماضي بالاضافه
الى تدمير مخزونات الصواريخ المجنحه
وقذائف اليورانيوم المنظم التي استلمتها
كييف من الغرب هكذا يؤكد كل طرف على
روايته في ضرب الاخر وتحقيق التقدم لكن
الاعين الان تتركز على القرم لتكون مسرح
العمليات الاوكرانيه المكثفه قبل الشتاء